With that boyish face, slick hair, slight
frame and pouty lips Audie Murphy could have
easily been one of those heartthrobs from
the James Dean era.
A rebel without a cause, a film star or a
pop recording artist.
He was, in fact, all of the above and then
some.
Audie Murphy was the real deal, one who could
talk the talk and walk the walk.
Aged barely 21, 2nd Lieutenant Audie Murphy
had fought his way from North Africa to France
in WWII, becoming the most decorated soldier
in US History – and a badass Axis-killing
machine.
In today’s Biographics video we will look
at the life of Audie Murphy and how he went
To Hell and Back.
1$ a day
Audie Leon Murphy was born on the 20th of
June 1925 in Kingston, Hunt County, Texas
in a family of poor sharecroppers of Irish
descent.
He did not have an easy life to start with.
Audie had to share a home with 11 siblings
with no abundance of food on the table.
Audie’s father, Emmett was not a model dad,
by any means, neglecting to provide for his
wife Josie Bell and their 12 children.
Young Audie felt a strong responsibility to
care for his family and quit school at an
early age, managing to complete only 5th grade.
He went to work in the Texas cotton fields,
earning a reputation as an indefatigable cotton
picker, which was well rewarded with the princely
pay of 1$ a day, 18$ in today’s money.
We don’t know who his employer was, but
I’ll take a guess and call him Stingy Bastard,
if you don’t mind.
There was little food you could buy with that
kind of money, so Audie had to resort to additional
means of sustenance.
At the age in which kids in the US nowadays
hunt for cute critters with their Pokemon
Go app, Audie Murphy also went hunting for
cute critters - with his rifle.
Squirrels, rabbits and other small game fell
under his shots and then onto Mum Josie’s
kitchen worktop.
The experience enabled Murphy to develop great
marksmanship skills, which would later prove
useful against another type of prey.
Growing into his teenage years, Audie looked
for other odd jobs, working as shop clerk
and gas station attendant.
I expect the pay was higher than 1$ a day,
but things went from bad to worse when in
1940 Emmett Murphy upped sticks and deserted
his family.
Audie’s mother Josie Bell died of pneumonia
the following year.
Suddenly Audie felt the weight of his family’s
welfare entirely on his narrow and frail shoulders.
Joining the Army
When the US were dragged into WWII by Japan’s
surprise attack on Pearl Harbour, 7th of December
1941, Audie Murphy thought “that’s it,
that’s what I am gonna do, I will join the
military!”.
He saw this not only as a means to provide
for his siblings, but also as a way to honour
his mother’s memory.
There was a slight problem, though.
Audie tried to enlist first with the Marines,
then with the paratroopers, but those elite
corps turned him down due to his diminutive
size and weak frame.
Audie in fact stood at only 5 foot 5 and weighed
a mere 110 pounds (that’s166 cm and 45 kilos)
– but he wasn’t going to accept such an
early setback.
It took him seven months, but he was able
to gain 12 pounds in weight.
Armed with this added bulk and his sister
false testimony that he was 18 – he was
actually 17 – he finally was inducted into
the military.
Not in the Marines, his armed force of choice,
but in the regular infantry.
After basic training at Camp Wolters, Texas,
and advanced training at Fort Meade, Maryland,
Audie was assigned to the famous 15th Infantry
Regiment and shipped off to North Africa.
The 15th landed in French Morocco in November
1942 as part of Operation Torch.
This consisted in attacking from the West
the Axis forces in North Africa, while the
British and Commonwealth forces were squeezing
the Italo-Germans from the East.
This was the first campaign in which American
forces would engage the Axis on land.
After initial setbacks at the Kasserine pass,
the Allied divisions, slowly but surely, encircled
the Italo-German armies in Tunisia.
They eventually surrendered in May 13, 1943
To Hell …
During the Tunisian Campaign Audie Murphy
did not saw combat.
But this was about to change: his first experience
of actual fighting occurred after the Allied
invasion of Sicily, in July 1943.
In a skirmish against Italian soldiers, Murphy
put to good use his natural hunting talent
and shot dead two officers.
This action earned him the first of many battlefield
promotions becoming a Corporal.
During the Italian campaign Audie consistently
impressed his superiors thanks to his courage,
resilience and innate leadership skills.
On one occasion he was hit by a German sniper
on the hip.
He did not lose his cool and returned fire,
hitting the sniper between the eyes.
But the only foes that managed to hold him
back in Italy were mosquitoes, as he spent
much time in a field hospital due to several
bouts of malaria.
In August 1944 Audie and the 15th Regiment
were in Southern France as part of Operation
Dragoon.
One day, Audie and his unit, which included
his best friend Lattie Tipton were lured out
of their fox hole by a group of surrendering
Germans.
It was a trap.
One of the Germans shot at Lattie, killing
him.
Audie simply went berserk.
He charged at the German squad and wiped them
out single-handedly.
He then grabbed their heavy machine gun and
grenades and put them to good use, attacking
several more German positions, killing all
enemy soldiers in the area.
Murphy received his first important decoration,
the Distinguished Service Cross, in recognition
of these actions.
This was a consistent trait of Murphy’s.
He would charge into battle in the most desperate
circumstances, always emerging alive – albeit
not unscathed – after inflicting tremendous
damage to the enemy, thanks to his nerves
of steel and excellent marksmanship.
As a reward, Murphy not only collected an
impressive number of medals, but he also escalated
the ranks.
By January 1945, aged barely 20, Audie had
moved from Private to Corporal to Sergeant
to 2nd Lieutenant.
It was on the 26th of that month that 2nd
Lieutenant Audie Murphy performed the action
that would make him a legend for the years
to come.
In the early afternoon of that day, Murphy
was leading a platoon of some 40 U.S. troops
in a clearing near the French town of Holtzwihr,
close to the German border.
The unit was charged with holding a roadway
until reinforcements arrived.
But the relief force did not materialise and
just after 2 p.m., the worst happened: 250
German troops supported by six tanks and an
artillery barrage emerged from the woods and
attacked.
Murphy’s first instinct was to get his men
to safety and so he instructed them to withdraw
to dug-in defensive positions along a nearby
tree line.
As they ran for cover, he stayed behind and
used his field telephone to call in an artillery
strike.
He managed to do so just in time, before the
Panzers opened fire against his position,
destroying a machine gun nest and setting
an American tank destroyer on fire.
But if there is something US soldiers can
rely upon is their artillery.
In few seconds, a barrage of shells exploded
between Murphy and the Germans.
The open field, which had been covered in
immaculate snow a few minutes before was now
a hellish landscape of craters.
Murphy took advantage of the cover offered
by the barrage and retreated atop the burning
tank destroyer.
Over the radio, the artillery commander asked
him how close the Germans were to his position.
He replied
“Just hold the phone and I’ll let you
talk to one of the bastards!”
Squad after squad of Germans seemed intent
on having a chat on the phone with the artillery
guy … but Murphy had found out that the
.50-caliber machine gun on top of the tank
destroyer was still operational.
He quickly opened fire, burst after burst,
mowing down dozens of enemy soldiers, all
the while directing artillery fire over the
radio.
German gunners fought back with small arms
and tank fire, with the shrapnel of one blast
wounding Murphy in the leg.
As usual, he kept on fighting.
It was only when the ammo on the machine gun
ran out that Murphy finally jumped from the
flaming tank destroyer and went back to his
men.
He later wrote that his only thought while
retreating was: “How come I’m not dead?”
Murphy had now reached safety behind the defensive
positions set up by his men.
He had personally killed or wounded about
50 enemies and taken out dozens more indirectly
via the artillery strike.
But he wasn’t done yet.
Murphy refused to be evacuated from the battlefield
and instead rallied his company into counterattacking
the Germans, finally driving them back into
the woods.
2nd Lieutenant Audie Murphy was awarded the
Medal of Honour for his actions at Holtzwihr.
The official citation which came with the
Medal reads
“Murphy's indomitable courage and his refusal
to give an inch of ground saved his company
from possible encirclement and destruction,
and enabled it to hold the woods which had
been the enemy's objective.”
Audie had now become something of a celebrity
among the Allied troops and his commanders
would rather have him as a liaison officer
rather than having risk his life on the front
line.
The last weeks of the war were relatively
peaceful for him – not that he needed to
see more actions.
By VE day Audie Murphy
Had endured three wounds and a nasty case
of malaria,
Had been promoted three times, from private
to officer
Had personally killed, wounded or captured
about 240 enemy soldiers
And had received a total of 33 decorations
from the US, French and Belgian militaries,
making him the most decorated soldier of WWII.
But he had also lost his best friend Lattie,
as well as countless other army buddies.
As he reflected immediately after the war
“There is VE-Day without, but no peace within.”
…
and
Back
Discharged from the Army on September 21,
1945, with the rank of 1st Lieutenant Audie
had barely made it back home, when Hollywood
actor and producer James Cagney noticed his
photo on the cover of a magazine.
Cagney was a real Hollywood legend, who had
become an A-lister in the 1930s thanks to
his roles in gangster movies.
Cagney had an eye for recognising talent and
immediately noticed in Audie’s boyish face
a certain star quality.
This was a turning point in Audie Murphy’s
life.
Was Cagney right?
Well, not really, at least at the beginning.
Hi company Cagney Productions paid for acting,
dancing and elocution lessons but in the following
years Murphy struggled to make his ‘big
break’, managing to score only two minor
roles, in Beyond Glory and Texas, Brooklyn
& Heaven, both in 1948.
If there is something we should have learned
about Murphy by now is that he was not easily
discouraged.
The following year, 1949, was a momentous
one for him.
After much auditioning he finally got his
first lead role as a juvenile delinquent in
Bad Boy.
Fun fact – the film’s director, Kurt Neumann,
was more famous for directing the Tarzan series
with Johnny Weissmuller and was a German from
Nuremberg.
That must have been awkward.
In addition to filming with Neumann, Audie
found time to publish his war memoire ‘To
Hell and Back’.
Written in a direct style, in the present
tense, Murphy’s book does not hold back
from the most atrocious realities of modern
war.
It would eventually become a best seller.
Last but not least, 1949 was also the year
in which Audie got married.
Just like Cagney had noticed Murphy on a magazine
cover, Audie had noticed his future wife,
actress Wanda Hendrix, on the front page of
Coronet.
Her beauty must have had the same effect of
being shelled by a Panzer.
Audie insisted to arrange a meeting with her,
and after a short engagement in 1948, the
two got married on the 8th of February 1949
and went on to act together in a Western film
called Sierra in 1950.
In 1951 Audie had the opportunity to be directed
by one of the greatest directors of all time,
John Houston, in MGM's The Red Badge of Courage.
This is now considered a classic but at the
time it bombed at the box office.
As a result, Murphy, now under binding contract
with Universal-International Pictures, was
assigned to star in a string of low-to-medium
budget Westerns, which was the genre which
suited best Audie’s acting talent - especially
his easy going image and Texas drawl, which
I am not going to imitate now.
He acted in a total of forty-four films, being
the main star in thirty-nine of them.
Despite most of these films have been forgotten
by now, it gave Murphy the opportunity to
work with Hollywood royalty such as actor
Jimmy Stewart or director Don Siegel, of ‘Dirty
Harry’ fame.
However, the role for which he is best remembered
is … as himself!
1955 in fact saw the release of "To Hell and
Back", adapted from his own war memoire, in
which Audie Murphy the actor starred as Audie
Murphy, the war hero.
‘To Hell and Back’ was a box office success
and remained Universal’s most profitable
picture for 20 years, until ‘Jaws; by Spielberg
was released.
It consecrated his status as a successful
actor and a household name, however it forced
him to relive the most traumatic experiences
of his service in WWII.
Back from Hell?
I have to apologise now if I have made you
think that Audie’s life was all fine and
dandy after returning from Germany.
It wasn’t.
Lieutenant Murphy had brought back with him
the demons of what had been called “shell
shock”, later “combat fatigue” and nowadays
post-traumatic stress disorder, or PTSD.
And Murphy displayed all the typical symptoms
of this condition, including nightmares, extreme
anxiety, irritability and insomnia.
This is how Audie described the agony and
misery he felt:
“"It is as though a fire had roared through
this human house, leaving only the charred
hulk of something that once was green."
He woke up screaming at night and slept with
a loaded calibre 45 pistol nearby.
He had a violent temper, so much so that in
a bar fight he inflicted such injuries on
his opponent that he was almost convicted
of attempted murder.
Don Siegel, who directed him in The Gun Runners
in 1958 reported that Audie often carried
a gun on set, with many of the cast and crew
being afraid of him.
His marriage with Wanda Hendrix suffered greatly
from his disorder.
Audie was often beset with flashbacks and
paranoia in the first months after the wedding
and often held Wanda at gunpoint during violent
episodes.
This must have degenerated in pathologic jealousy,
as Murphy demanded from his wife – by then
a much more successful actress than he was
– that she gave up her job to be a stay-at-home
wife.
Wanda was frightened by this behaviour and
left him after only seven months of marriage,
charging him with mental cruelty.
The final decree of divorce came on April
14, 1950.
Murphy married again the following year with
Pamela Archer, also an actress.
This union would be a happier one, lasting
until Audie’s death.
But his troubles with insomnia and depression
continued throughout the 1960s, in parallel
with his declining film career.
In the end he became addicted to a powerful
prescription drug called Placidyl which actually
can worsen a pre-existing state of depression.
Audie Murphy, though, was never one to raise
a white flag.
Realizing he had become addicted to Placidyl,
he locked himself in a motel room for a week,
while he went full cold turkey and fought
back the withdrawal symptoms.
He ended up beating the addiction and went
on to break the taboo of talking about the
mental disorders many soldiers suffered when
they returned home.
His willingness to do so opened up for the
first time Nation-wide discussions about psychological
care for Korean and Vietnam war veterans upon
their return to the US.
Meanwhile, the studio system that Murphy grew
into as an actor crumbled.
Universal's new owners, MCA turned the studio's
focus toward the now more lucrative television
industry.
For theatrical productions, it dropped its
roster of contract players and hired actors
on a per-picture basis only.
What this meant for Murphy is that he now
had to audition and hustle for each role,
just like at the beginning of his career.
This was made even more difficult by the fact
that the traditional, mid-budget Westerns
he had become famous for, they were now a
thing of the past.
The 1960s were the age of counter-culture
and the Frontier was now represented by the
new wave of European-made ‘Spaghetti Westerns’.
Audie tried his hand at the new genre, landing
the leading role in ‘The Texican’, in
1966, which is more precisely a “Paella
Western”, as the majority of the cast was
Spanish.
Apparently, it is not as terrible as it sounds
– but it tanked at the box office.
As a soldier, he had garnered 33 medals; as
an actor the only official accolade was a
1955 prize as “Movie Distributors’ Favourite
Western Actor”.
Fortunately, Murphy had diversified his activities
becoming also a rancher and businessman in
the trade of breeding and selling thoroughbred
horses.
He had also become a songwriter, writing the
lyrics to many pop and country hits of the
1960s.
His most famous song, Shutters and Boards,
was recorded by legendary crooner Dean Martin
among others and was even covered in Swedish.
It is easy to find in the lyrics an echo of
the failed romance with Wanda.
Now, I’d love to play it for you but unfortunately
my guitar is being re-strung, so I will just
read you some lines:
“Shutters and boards cover the windows
Of the house where we used to live
All I have left is a heart full of sorrow
Since she said she'd never forgive
The house that we built was once filled with
laughter
But I changed that laughter to tears
Now I must live in a world without sunshine
Oh how I wish you were here”
From Hell to Heaven
On May 28th, 1971, Murphy was flying on a
private plane, on his way to a business meeting.
According to many accounts, by this point
he had largely lost his fortune to gambling
and bad investments.
Perhaps this meeting was to set him back on
the good track, but we will never now.
The plane ran into thick fog over Craig County,
Virginia, near Roanoke, and crashed into the
side of a mountain.
Audie and all five other passengers and crew
were killed.
He was buried with full military honours at
Arlington National Military Cemetery, on June
the 7th.
According to cemetery records, the only grave
site visited by more people than that of Murphy
is that of President John F. Kennedy